if you were really smart you wouldn't
need a calculator to know there was
something wrong
yeah there was a there was a short story
called the devil and Simon Flagg where
Simon Flagg makes a deal with the devil
and part of that deal is that he can
keep his soul if the devil can prove
Fermat's Last Theorem and of course the
devil can't prove their mouth last there
were Muslim crops up in Star Trek X to
the N plus white at the end equals Z to
the end it crops up in Doctor Who the
11th doctor in order to prove himself
rewrites film as original programmers
fear of the truth pops up in bedazzled
the film with Liz Hurley where she plays
a devil as well so it's quite a devilish
link to fairmark pops up in Arcadia
played by Tom Stoppard so so it's very
much a bit of math that people can use
in novels and films and plays because it
sort of has a bit of glamour around it
and people have perhaps vaguely heard of
it recently I I spotted it in an episode
of The Simpsons because there's a
there's an episode called The Wizard of
Evergreen Terrace where Homer Simpson
wants to become an inventor and he has a
blackboard and he seems scribbling
things on the blackboard and one of the
equations that Homer Simpsons writes on
the blackboard is an apparent solution
to Fermat's Last Theorem it's some four
digit number to the twelfth power plus a
four-digit number to the twelfth power
equals a four-digit number to the
twelfth power
now firmers Last Theorem says that that
should not exist so Homer is defying
firma and Andrew Wiles now if you have a
little phone calculator and you type in
the digits and you check homers solution
which should not exist turns out a
perfectly valid solution hang on a
second this is a this is a big problem
and the solution to the problem is it is
it's called a near-miss solution which
means that if you've got a phone
calculator with only 10 decimal places
you won't see the problem but if you go
to 15 or 20 decimal places you'll see
that the about the equation doesn't
quite balance it's very very close but
not quite there his solution is 3987 to
the power 12 plus
4365 to the power 12 equals 4472 to the
power 12 try that out on your phone
calculator it'll kind of make sense it's
not the only near-miss in the Simpsons
there's another one in an episode called
homer cubes which is part of the
treehouse of horror 6 episode of The
Simpsons and when I saw the second one I
remember thinking there's somebody on
the Simpsons who clearly likes maths and
the culprit is a chap called David X
Cohen the David X Cohen is did physics
at Harvard I did physics as well and
physicists like maths so that that kind
of explains David's obsession with
mathematics he then did a master's
degree in computer science and then went
on and published research papers in
mathematics in fact there's a whole area
of mathematics known as pancake flipping
which is a whole other story but David
David X Cohen is a serious mathematician
who found his way into the Simpsons and
so every so often in the Simpsons he
will drop in little bits of mathematics
when David X Cohen drops in these false
solutions to fer Mars Last Theorem
he's kind of nodding back to his past
and his love of mathematics and then the
really weird thing is it he's not the
only mathematician on The Simpsons there
are this guy called Al Jean who did
mathematics at Harvard there's a guy
called Ken Keeler who has a PhD in
applied math there's a guy called Mike
Reiss who is corresponding with the
great mathematician Martin Gardner the
great recreational mathematician Martin
Gardner when he was a young kid so there
are a lot of mathematicians on the
Simpsons and they all drop in bits of
math in the Simpsons what should we read
into the fact that all these
mathematicians are on The Simpsons
writing stuff um it's tricky I spoke to
I met them last year and I said to him
why so why have you all ended up as
being comedy writers and and they gave
me various theories one theory that many
of them share is that mathematicians
love logic and therefore they love blade
breaking logic and playing with logic
and they love the illogical
and a lot of humor is based on that one
explanation that Al Jean gave me as to
why they work in animation in particular
is that animation is all about control
what you storyboard
what you script appears on screen in
mathematics what you write down on paper
is what happens now we can contrast that
with a real action sitcom where you
don't have control you know the actors
will put in their idea scripts will
change scenes will change everything is
up for grabs and science is a bit like
that is what we need a science
experiment things change things go wrong
test tubes break etc so there does seem
to be a very strong link between
mathematicians and comedy and
mathematicians who write comedy who then
work in animation when we took like
near-misses we're looking at it kind of
proportionally is it a near-miss so
we're looking for digit numbers to the
twelfth power so we're looking at 48
digit numbers and so if they're out by
millions and millions that's only a tiny
amount because we're looking at such
massive digits and so on most
calculators you won't see the error if
you were really smart you wouldn't need
a calculator to know there was something
wrong in one of these if you look at the
second one now this one is obviously
wrong now the reasons obviously wrong is
because this is an even number that's an
odd number that's an even number and
even number to the 12 power must still
be an even number an odd number to the
12 pair must be an odd number and even
number plus an odd number is an odd
number so that cannot equal that you
were talking about this near-miss or
these two near-misses that were put in
yes he does he is he paying tribute to
something here or is he trolling it's
even control no it's very much you know
we need when you love something and I
think David's coming loves comedy he
loves comedy writing and he loves
mathematics it's natural to try and
bring the two together you don't force
them together and the mathematics in the
Simpsons never gets in the way of the
plot but if there's an opportunity to
drop something in that you love yeah in
the very first episode of The Simpsons
one of the kids has a lunch
box with Anatoly Karpov picture on now I
remember Anatoly Karpov is a great chess
player of the early 70s now I guess
somebody on The Simpsons writing team is
also a fan of chess and a fan of vanette
Ollie Karpov and so these things get
dropped in and as there are so many
mathematical writers on The Simpsons
they drop in an awful lot of these
mathematical notes
if you'd like to help Simon buy some new
monkeys to hang on those bookshelves of
his why don't you have a look at his
book it's out this week it's all about
mathematics in the Simpsons of course
I'll put a link so you can check out the
book in the video description there will
also be links to our other videos about
for Mars Last Theorem that we filmed
with Simon and released earlier this
week and lastly I'm also including a
link to a sixty symbols video I uploaded
this week all about the physics of water
balloons and filming them in slow motion
it's really good and I know a lot of
people have been having problems with
their subscription boxes on YouTube this
week so if you subscribe to sixty
symbols which is like our sort of sister
channel but about physics and you missed
that one well now you've got no excuse